this episode is sponsored by blinkist
blinkist puts all of the need to know
information from
thousands of non-fiction books and
condenses them down
into just 15 minutes and you can go to
blinkist.com
microcosmos to learn more
[Music]
there are plenty of ways to get food in
the micro cosmos
but the cilia driven vortex seems
particularly charming
the microbes who use this method can
graze
in place if they want to stirring up
whirls and
whirls and whirls of water to draw food
in towards them rotifers like this
philadena here
use the crown of cilia around their head
to create that movement in the water and
cycle
food like algae into closer proximity
but watch carefully if you tap the slide
and momentarily shocked the rotifer into
curling inward
it'll stop juggling its algae meal
and more strikingly the algae itself
immediately stops moving any additional
movement you see in the algae is because
the rotifer's movements
are displacing the water when the
rotifers cilia were in motion the algae
looked like they were caught up in a
fast-moving whirlpool now it's almost
like they're
stuck in molasses and in a way
they kind of are it is not that the
algae are
actually in molasses like all our other
samples they're living it up
in good old h2o and of course
to us liquid water is a flowing thing
we can swim through it jump into it run
our
hands through it gather samples for this
show from it
all with relative ease but for microbes
water isn't like that it's like a syrup
and while life in syrup sounds whimsical
the mechanics and math that explains it
is much less so and thus
we are going to give you just a very
broad
idea of what's going on here warning
fluid dynamics ahead
the way things move in a fluid is an
extremely
complex dynamic thing that's
characterized
and defined in many different ways but
the most useful description for us is
what's called
the reynolds number which tells us
whether or not the movement we're
interested in
is dominated by inertia or viscosity
when the reynolds number is higher the
inertial forces dominate which means
that an
object or fluid that is gliding is more
likely to keep on gliding
and when the reynolds number is lower
the viscous
forces dominate and that brings things
to a halt
[Music]
if we're comparing things moving in
water then one of the most useful things
to note
is that an organism's reynolds number
will generally
increase with its size a person swimming
in water
might have a reynolds number that's on
the order of 10 000
which lets us glide a little between
each stroke a blue whale
might be somewhere on the order of a
hundred million
which lets it travel quite far with just
a flap of its tail bacteria by
comparison
they're working with a reynolds number
that's more on the order of
0.00001
and where a whale or a person can travel
multiple body lengths depending on how
we generate
power a bacteria that's been pushed by
something else
will only travel about a tenth of the
diameter
of a hydrogen atom before coming to a
stop
that is not far
so for the microcosmos water is not the
lovely flowing thing that we know and
love it's
thick and syrupy and it should be a
challenge to move through but as you may
have noticed
many of these microbes are still plenty
fast sometimes we get
questions about whether we've sped up
the footage and the answer is that
unless we've otherwise noted any changes
in speed
that is the real-time speed of these
organisms
even in this clip the various
flagellates and ciliates
are moving quite fast and that's after
we slowed down the footage
500 percent so like
how how can they move so fast
in syrup we went into more detail about
how single-celled eukaryotes do this
many episodes ago some use cilia others
use flagella
and while these are different structures
with their own motions the effect is the
same
cilia and flagella generate thrust which
keeps the organism moving
so protists have evolved these various
appendages that allow them
to move in a viscous environment and
that's because
movement is essential whether it's
within a confined area
or freely through space it takes hunters
to
their prey and it takes prey away from
their hunters
[Music]
so for microbes the syrupy world around
them
is actually quite important and it's one
scientists are working to understand
better
they've studied how these didn'tium
chased their prey and
changing temperatures and viscosity they
found
that increasing the viscosity of
erotifer's surroundings slowed its
population growth
and they've tested how viscosity affects
bacterial movement too
these responses are important for
understanding not only the individual
lives of microbes and the ecosystems
they live in
they're important for understanding our
own bodies
because to many microbes we are just
another
strange geographic feature to live in
we're a living bag of fluids that
bacteria
often find their way into and how they
navigate our body
deeply impacts our health
spirochetes for example cause lyme
disease and syphilis
but to do that they have to get through
blood and other fluids which they do
in this erratic corkscrew motion the
bacteria is generating thrust with
flagella
though it's important to note that
bacterial flagella
are a completely distinct thing from the
eukaryotic flagella we mentioned earlier
and spirochetes use their flagella in a
way that's weird even for bacteria
they keep their flagella inside them
sandwiched between their membranes and
as the flagella rotate internally they
drive the entire spirochete
to rotate and move this mechanism
doesn't just move the spirochete it also
helps them
dig deeper into the dense bits inside us
that are more difficult for other
bacteria to penetrate
and that's just one example of how a
life in
syrup impacts us sometimes the syrup is
water
and sometimes it's you but for microbes
it's just home
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore
the unseen world that surrounds us
do you have trouble finding time to sit
down and read all of the books that are
stacked in your to be red pile either in
your nightstand or
just in your head well blinkist is here
not only to save your nightstand but
also to help you
develop yourself and learn new things
blinkist highlights the most important
insights and need to know information
from non-fiction books
and condenses them down so that you can
either read or listen to them
in just 15 minutes and if you're looking
to learn even more about the microcosmos
you can do so
by checking out books like the tangled
tree by david quammen
or i contain multitudes by ed yong which
are both
available on blinkist whether you're
interested in science
history self-help or business blinkist
has something for you
in the 3000 plus titles in its library
so even if you don't have the time for
all the books you want to read
you can still find the time to learn new
things
blinkist has more than 12 million users
and if you're one of the first
hundred people to sign up today at
blinkist.com
microcosmos you can get free unlimited
access
for seven days and you'll also get 25
off if you decide to get a full
membership
thank you so much to all of the people
whose names are on the screen right now
these are our patreon patrons without
them
we could not make journey to the micro
cosmos
so if you like what you see these are
the folks to thank
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss check out jam
and germs on instagram
and if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
you